foreign
phobia means an intense fear of deep
water it is one of the most Primal and
understandable phobias for the dark
abyss has always been a birthplace of
monsters
lurking below the waves are not only
bizarre species known to science but a
vast multitude of imagined leviathans
something about the fathomless void
floods the human mind with visions of
nightmarish creatures which have scared
and fascinated us since we first gazed
into the deep so for this entry into the
archive we'll dive into depths both real
and imagined and discover what Terrors
lurk within the heart of the sea
beginning of descent
cruising depths in roughly 40 seconds
standby
I'll begin with the game iron long where
you play as a convict sealed inside a
cramped submarine exploring depth so far
below the vessel's safety limit that the
only window has to be welded shut
it's a good starting point because
despite its retro style Graphics I
believe that short of falling into the
Mariana Trench it's the closest you can
get to experiencing the terror of the
deep sea firsthand
iron lung takes place in the wake of an
event called The Quiet Rapture in which
every known star and habitable planet
just vanished leaving behind only those
who were on space stations in one
remaining moon is now covered in what
seems to be an ocean of blood and it's
this ocean you're diving beneath very
relaxing stuff
with the window welded shut your only
way of navigating is using a primitive
radar system that pings when you're near
a wall but soon you start to get pings
even when you're in Open Water the sole
method of checking what's out there is
using a camera that essentially works
like an old Polaroid taking a few
nail-biting seconds to process the image
at first despite the pings on the radar
You See No Monsters but you do see other
things mysterious bones that defy
explanation twisting structures that
almost resemble pipes even impossibly
what seems to be the remains of a
building until eventually you take a
picture and in the corner
it's hard to convey how frightening this
moment is because of the delay you know
that the creature might be right on top
of you but you take another picture and
it's gone like there was nothing there
at all
as you continue despite the vastness of
the sea around you the interior of the
sub comes to feel paradoxically
claustrophobic made worse by
malfunctions like sudden electrical
fires later The Vessel starts flooding
blood rising up to your waist eventually
a huge object appears on the radar and
when you go to take a photo
this was about where I hit my limit
which is a testament to how expertly
Iron long uses its minimalist mechanics
to simulate the terror of the crushing
depths while its ocean of blood is of
course fictional the dreaded conjures
seems drawn from real encounters with
the deep sea
frightening experiences with the ocean
aren't anything new stories of sea
monsters likely inspired by fleeting
encounters with Abyssal marine life have
existed since our first days of
seafaring but for much of History many
regarded the idea of Life surviving in
the deep as Superstition in the 19th
century the popular Abyss theory
proposed by naturalist Edward Forbes
held that no species could exist deeper
than 300 meters or one thousand feet
below the ocean surface while later
studies would contradict this idea it
wasn't until 1930 that someone attempted
to dive below such depths to see for
themselves naturalist William BB
alongside Otis Barton plunged further
into the abyss than any human had before
in a metal tank called the bathysphere
and what they saw changed science
forever
fish that flashed with bioluminescent
color see-through predators of the deep
surreal invertebrates that glided on
Fantastical fins one can only imagine
what it was like for someone in the
early 20th century to see the alien
sights of the deep for the first time
especially when you consider that the
men were observing the abyss in a
heavily altered state of mind as both
were battered and concussed from a bumpy
Voyage down perhaps it's no surprise
then that not all the fish they claim to
have seen have been identified Bibi
stated he saw a bizarre creature named
the five-lined constellation fish and
while no such species has ever been
spotted again the description Bears a
striking resemblance to a deep sea comb
jelly which Bibi might have interpreted
as a fish unable to comprehend its true
form even more incredibly Bibi claimed
that two giant dragon fish larger than
the sub itself swam by which have also
never been documented since it's
possible that once again Bibi saw
another deep sea species and
misidentified it or it's possible that
these Giants have simply eluded
detection
in either case The bathosphere's Descent
and others like it flooded the public
Consciousness with visions of the watery
depths over the next few decades
numerous leviathans rose up from the
abyss and into early Cinema with movies
about aquatic monsters terrorizing the
land becoming exceedingly popular one of
the most famous of these films was the
1954 adaption of Jules Verne's 20 000
Leagues Under the Sea a movie with
Origins even older than the bathysphere
the novel it's based on comes from 1870
and actually predicted the invention of
submarines making it foundational to all
sci-fi interpretations of the deep sea
leading into the modern era the vast
majority of films about the ocean have
continued to portray it as a hostile
realm nearly everything about the
Uncharted depths lends itself to horror
from the crushing pressure to the low
visibility to the bizarre creatures that
swim in the Gloom the deep sea can be so
alien some works of sci-fi have imagined
it is home to literal aliens in James
Cameron's the abyss humans make first
contact with a group of advanced aquatic
extraterrestrials who settled in Earth's
oceans long ago the film seems to take
inspiration from in the abyss by early
sci-fi novelist H.G Wells in which an
Explorer discovers a similar hidden
Society of intelligent undersea beings
perhaps it should come as no surprise
the ocean is portrayed as a hideaway for
extraterrestrials as many real deep sea
species seem like they'd be right at
home on another planet take for example
the barrel eye fish an animal with
translucent skin that allows it to look
upwards through its head to spot prey or
the vampire squid a cephalopod whose
Underside is covered with fearsome
looking spikes to ward off Predators the
life forms of the depths can be so
unsettling it's understandable that most
media interprets it as a terrifying
Realm
get a greater understanding of the
oceans hasn't just led to fearful
artistic reactions ebbzoo is a soothing
video game that makes a stirring case
for the beauty of the undersea realm
following the voyage of a diver through
stunning Marine environments the
gameplay involves no combat or survival
mechanics instead you spend your time
drifting through Shoals of simulated
fish taking the flipper of a porpoise
and leaping over the waves or diving
with giants of the deep abzu invites you
into the Beating Heart of the Ocean
where every moment thrums with the
Rhythm of Life at the same time it is a
game that politely asks you to let your
mind wander to let go of your fears and
meditate on the calm Vistas around you
but even in the cheeriest most brightly
lit renderings of the ocean there are
often moments where the dread of the
vast Abyss Creeps in one major example
of this appears in Beyond blue an
underwater exploration game where you
catalog different species of marine life
compared to abzu Beyond blue takes a
less stylized but equally peaceful
approach to underwater exploration yet
even though it's not intended to
frighten there are parts of this game
that I find scarier than the entirety of
certain horror titles there's a moment
in Beyond blue where from the pitch
black void a giant squid attacks your
camera before disappearing again into
the unknown the game shows that even in
an educational context the deep can be
unintentionally unsettling
perhaps the ultimate example of
accidental horror is subnautica a series
that plunges you into the alien Seas of
a distant planet subnautica in its
sequel bring you face to face with so
many nightmarish aquatic Predators
they're often described as horror games
or at least horror adjacent yet that
wasn't the intention when the game was
in initial development originally
subnautica was planned to be a more
relaxed cruise through an aquatic realm
but early testers kept getting
frightened by the unknown depths leading
developers to realize the potential the
game had as a more intense experience
yet the power of subnautica comes from
more than just jump scares the game will
stun you with the vastness of Mega
funnel filter feeders but funnel you
with the bizarreness of unclassifiable
oddities and bewilder you with the
Blurred light of bioluminescent wonders
though not set on Earth perhaps more
than any game subnautica presents the
experience of the ocean in its totality
a realm that inspires both awe and
Terror I think it's curious then that
despite crafting a painstakingly complex
diverse biosphere of simulated life
subnautica is typically remembered as a
game designed only to terrify in today's
market subnautica doesn't seem like it
should be able to frighten audiences
there is no killer chasing you no
ax-wielding Maniac just around the
corner threats that are much closer to
us land dwellers than something
thousands of feet below the waves and
yet The Dread that subnautica evokes can
be overwhelming all-encompassing to the
point where you forget the more peaceful
parts of the ocean and vowed and never
dip a toe in the water again
even when the ocean isn't presented as
something frightening the vast majority
of humans still feel some uneasiness
towards the immeasurable deep in regions
where the light dims and visibility
drops off or rational mind Fades out in
our animal mind checks in and gets to
work frightening us Conjuring images of
immense leviathans twisting just out of
sight
of course it doesn't help that there are
leviathans in the depths Abyssal
gigantism is the scientific term for the
tendency of deep sea dwelling animals to
grow far larger than their shallow water
relatives while there are some proposed
explanations for this phenomenon the
inaccessibility of Abyssal habitats
means that there's still much we don't
know about the Giants of our own oceans
it can make you feel like anything might
be down there and that can cause
problems a few years ago an Infamous
Discovery Channel documentary took
advantage of the ocean's potential to
conceal monsters and suggested the long
extinct shark the Megalodon still swam
in the oceans this concept gained so
much traction in the public eye that it
seemingly inspired the Meg a movie in
which is somehow still living Megalodon
attacks modern beachgoers while it's
easy to laugh at the fact that so many
people believed a prehistoric shark
still lived that a major Studio made a
multi-million dollar Blockbuster about
it this cultural phenomenon shows the
power of the ocean's unknowable vastness
to trigger human imagination
yet many of us had our trust shattered
years earlier with the release of a
mockumentary called mermaids the body
found this widely aired faux documentary
sets out to convince you that mermaids
are real hominids descended from aquatic
apes and for the time it was pretty
convincing using fake cave paintings
manufactured artifacts and even full CGI
Recreations to lend plausibility to the
Absurd concept the film honestly goes so
far into fictional mermaid biology it
almost feels like a work of speculative
Evolution it even folds in real world
unusual phenomena like the bloop and
claims they were the result of mermaids
for those of you who don't know the
bloop is a strange underwater noise
recorded in 2002 that was many orders of
magnitude louder than even the largest
whale calls while the sound instigated
speculation of an Undiscovered creature
further analysis shows it was almost
certainly the result of a glacier moving
but the speed at which these hoaxes and
misunderstandings have spread shows that
the skeptical part of our psyches shuts
down when it comes to gazing into the
abyss it's no accident that one of the
most widely reported childhood fears is
of a shark lurking in the deep end of a
swimming pool plausibility doesn't
matter when it comes to Deep Water
anything could be waiting down below
yet paradoxically Sometimes the best way
to convey the power of the ocean is to
reveal very little of it and few pieces
of media make use of the Unseen better
than the anxiety-inducing water womb
World a deeply surreal pixel art game
created by Indie designer yames the game
follows a religious man who believes
he's found the origin point of life deep
below the waves the game is dark not
just thematically but literally at any
given moment the vast majority of pixels
on screen are pure black as you gaze out
from your helmet into the unyielding
vacuum of the ocean much of the gameplay
involves sifting through silt where you
find things that should be there like a
pair of goggles and things that
definitely shouldn't like a human skull
that's over 10 000 years old the more
unsettling objects you find the more you
become convinced that a big scare is
coming that any moment now something
will pop out of the darkness but nothing
comes until back at your undersea lab
you hear this
[Music]
returning to the abyss you find the
darkness is more all-encompassing than
ever and then from the Gloom emerges
this
the main character interprets the being
as an angel and continues to dig up
increasingly disturbing artifacts while
their mind and body become increasingly
diseased and the ending comes not long
after that for water womb world is a
short game offering only a tiny glimpse
of a far wider realm of nightmares which
only adds to how unsettling it is in the
same way that the ocean's Dreadful power
comes from how much of it we've never
seen the game's restraint makes its
atmosphere of unease all the more
palpable
another indie game that captures the
oceans might despite never showing much
of it is in other waters although the
game is focused on exploring a vast
alien sea teaming with life the entirety
of the game's environment is
communicated through nothing but text
and minimal icons in most games you have
a heads up display in the bottom corner
to help you keep track of various
in-game systems but when playing in
other waters the entire game is the
heads-up display while this can take
some getting used to it's a clever way
for a smaller budget game to feel
expansive as you play you learn to
visualize each life form as they're
described picturing luminous creatures
gliding through the water armored life
forms with tough shells or fungal
organisms that grow in Endless rows it's
a game that embodies the enigmatic
nature of the ocean taking advantage of
the human instinct to imagine what swims
below opaque Waters
the ocean doesn't need to be filled with
imagined monsters to instill dread
though even singular real data points
can be haunting Point Nemo for example
is a spot in the Pacific Ocean that
seems utterly uninteresting except for
the fact that it's the furthest place on
Earth from any land should you find
yourself floating at Point Nemo the
closest people to you or the astronauts
on board the International Space Station
when it passes overhead
yet monsters are a primal part of our
relationship with the deep and for our
last stop on this plunge into the void
there's one final Leviathan we need to
confront
scp-3000 is an entry into the famous
Community Driven paranormal Anthology
the SCP series and is perhaps the
ultimate personification of the sea
monster archetype
scp-3000 is in the simplest terms a
giant eel measuring over 850 kilometers
or 500 miles in length located somewhere
in the Indian Ocean it also secretes a
substance that causes Amnesia and mental
shutdown although just seeing such a
large creature could cause anyone to
lose their mind and that's basically the
whole concept considering how complex
many entries into the SCP series are
it's noteworthy that scp-3000 is one of
the most famous inspiring incredible fan
art and animation despite its relative
Simplicity there's something about the
purity of an unfathomably vast eel that
just works made all the more intriguing
by the fact that the eel isn't
aggressive or curious it simply is to me
it's the ultimate oddly reassuring proof
that even in the age of the internet or
innate fear and fascination with giants
of the deep hasn't left us
in the end perhaps it shouldn't come as
a surprise that the watery Abyss still
holds power over the human psyche the
ocean is deep space in our backyard an
alien realm of alien creatures right
here on Earth as long as a significant
percentage of the deep blue remains
unmapped we will never cease to
speculate on what swims beneath the
waves despite our rational Minds telling
us otherwise in the depths where light
cannot penetrate the monsters of our
oldest myths will continue to lurk
forever just out of sight
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
thank you